[Musique]
le pesto classique à la barre ces
composés de cinq langues réseau vraiment
simple on parle de basilic died de noix
de pin de parmesan râpé parfois notre
fromage le nom de pecorino et de l'huile
d'olive extra vierge faciles à préparer
à la maison en saison le pesto tire ses
origines des cuisines de perth et de
l'ancien rhône à l'époque on utilisait
un mortier pour piles et les herbes
mélangé avec de l'huile pour en faire un
condiment maintenant différentes régions
d'italie exaspérant resto donc dans le
sud de l'été lyon ne suis souvent
légèrement dans d'autres régions vont
utiliser les pistaches donc si le pesto
traditionnel mais il ya des variantes
depuis quelques années on peut trouver
en épicerie ce condiment utilisé dans de
nombreux plats un produit qui a gagné en
popularité au fil des ans
ça fait à peu près 12 ans 15 ans le
premier pas stocker mis sur le marché on
a sorti fait marcher parce qu'il fait le
vendait pas
c'est à peu près 4 50 qu'on a retenu
avec le pesto et d'un croissant chaque
année
si bien que nous avons recensé qu'un
spéciaux offerts en supermarché sept
sont des produits frais vendus
réfrigérée et 8 se vendent en conserve
sur les tablettes
[Musique]
la nutritionniste vanessa peron a grandi
dans une famille italienne
elle constate que la liste d'ingrédients
de certains produits s'éloigne du pesto
traditionnels quand on parle d'
authenticité on regarde vraiment ces
produits si qui s'éloigne du pesto ce
pour différentes raisons il y en a
certains qui contiennent pas de moi
certains qui concerne pas d'huile
d'olive dans certains pesto du commerce
on utilise peu ou pas de l'huile d'olive
et ce ne serait pas uniquement une
question de coût non c'est pas seulement
le bruit
pour cela le bris mais il n'a fait parce
que l'huile d'olive dans le frigo
ça devient tout comme et déjà l'été
l'huile d'olive il fallait robots dans
le fluo fille à l'heure à il faut être
aussi après ça on peut mieux fallu être
vers une politique
est-ce que parmi nos quinze postes
oyonnax qui correspondent à la
définition de ce qu'est un véritable le
pesto wind y en a quelques-uns on parle
de ceux ci donc le pastel le veer italia
on parle de suite de pc noir puis on à
le virer aussi j'ai aussi intégré à la
liste celui ci malgré qu'ils ne
contiennent pas de newark donc pas
techniquement un pesto et qui se trouve
avoir une bonne liste des ingrédients
donc une belle option pour ceux qui
visent in moi c'est là son plus moteur
vert clair c'est effectivement ce ne
sont plus épais aussi le meurtre dans
leurs textes sombres
nous avons demandé à deux grands
amateurs de pesto de basilic de goûter
les produits d'épicerie afin de
déterminer lesquels se rapproche des
pesto maison sachem passons
moi je trouve pas que ça ça goûte le
basilic je trouve que ça goûte l'herbe
beaucoup de pesto contiennent d'autres
herbes que le brésil et en particulier
du père si le public le plus fragile que
le père fils ça devient brun pas
tellement le basilic est là le passé les
laisse un peu exception fait pas simple
le prix où le gouvernement se bat pour
laisser les couleurs qu'elle ait fait un
peu plus vert plus plus longtemps
certains fabricants ajoutent également
des flocons de pommes de terre un peu
négatif sur le côté ça fait comme
gélatineux c'est pas agréable
comme tous les produits transformés les
pesto contiennent beaucoup de sodium
parmi tous les produits qu'on a étudié y
en avait seulement 3 qui était ressortie
comme étant adéquat en termes de
pourcentage de valeur quotidienne pour
le sodium c'est à dire qu'ils étaient en
dessous du 15 % on avait ces trois
produits si on avait le sarde au frais
on avait celui de irrésistible celui de
fontaine santé pour tous les autres on
se retrouvait à voir une teneur trop
élevé ça c'est mes gosses à lui très
salée paul von très très salée avec
d'autres sur le fromage
ça monte jusqu'à 8 110 mg donc l'écart
est grand parmi ces produits là c'est
quelque chose qui dépend beaucoup de les
ingrédients qui sont utilisés on parle
d'un ingrédient qui sont sales et de
base le fromage parmesan et j'étais pas
donc ça revient à l'idée d'utiliser le
pesto comme en assaisonnement donc
évidemment si on prend 75 pour un plat
complet puis on divise en quatre
portions c'est sûr qu'on va finir par
avoir une teneur bac - cassel qingqi
décrite comme de protéines est ce que
c'est quelque chose qu'on devrait
d ou pas ou la protéine principal mais
pas de sens la protéine principal
viendrait pas de se produire
on ne dépendrait pas de notre apport
protéine sur1 pesto et puis ça varie
énormément puis c'est aussi à cause là
les ingrédients donc les protéines on va
retrouver notamment dans le fromage dans
les noirs commencent à se trouver des
favoris partout fait remonter peu de
pesto préparés ont rallié nourou tall je
préférais le dos
c'est le 12
il est salée mais le texte soit plus
agréable et un meilleur goût a pu
améliorer son concepteur
il va avoir le 12 va voir ailleurs goût
un meilleur texture une mais un meilleur
aspect visuel piloter et c'est celui que
j'avais dit qu'ils étaient sales et un
réduisent et c'est vraiment salim et
autres comme pour moi pas agréable mais
encore là peut-être que son départ que
tu salle pas trop dans l'autre ça c'est
ça passerait il y aurait sommé une autre
saveur
il y en a pas un conte peuvent diriger
vraiment super basilic et corinne ou
parmesan
puis un noir peint fait il y en a aucun
qui a vraiment juste les éléments qu'il
faut quand tu achètes quelque chose qui
est déjà travaillé industriellement rsa
pas le même goût que si tu fais toi même
et qu'en pense notre nutritionniste
on y va à fond dans le groupe i dont
elle a la qualité des ingrédients dont
je dirais ceci pour une psychose tout à
l'heure pour la portion puis puis parce
que la valeur nutritive c'est rien c'est
rien de très alarmant
mais pour vanessa et nos buteurs rien ne
vaut un pesto frais qui ne demande que
quelques ingrédients et cinq minutes de
notre temps dégustation de citation puis
très bon toi ses frais on a le goût du
basilic qui dominèrent la goutte lannoy
un peu la nôtre la texture est belle
aussi lol ces bonnes pratiques de le
faire soi même à la maison ça nous
permet de contrôler la qualité les
ingrédients et surtout de vraiment ce
départ n'est à l'année
[Musique]